[Music]
on the news are here at al jazeera and
there is breaking news on the current
covert situation it's coming out of
belgium
which has confirmed a first case of the
new coronavirus variant the one we were
telling you about a little bit earlier
which has been detected
uh in south africa and has prompted a
number of countries to review their
travel restrictions european nations
particularly rushing to impose those uh
restrictions dominick kane in berlin uh
with more on this and the coveted
situation across europe this is you know
we don't want to get alarmist too
quickly but this is exactly the kind of
thing which government's worried about
the virus being on the move
yes this is as you say exactly the thing
that the ministers and medics around
this continent would fear the thought
that a new variant which has been
described as being of really serious
concern and that a person or persons
have now been detected or have it in
their system certainly
some reports say two people have been
found with this variant in their systems
in belgium but all agree that at least
one person has and that one person has
been confirmed by a belgian minister now
the important thing to stress about this
is the person concerned it is it is
reported tested
positive for kovids on the 22nd of
november that's monday of this week and
they were unvaccinated
now clearly in many eu countries right
now you have levels of vaccination in
the population of around two-thirds
perhaps more in some cases so clearly
from the governmental perspective
but right across the eu you have the eu
as an institution in the shape of
president of the commission of
underlying really concerned about this
new variant detected in south africa or
in southern africa and calling for
governments to restrict access from
people who've been in southern africa to
the eu and now you have this
confirmation from the belgian government
that at least one person has tested
positive in the course of the last few
days for this new variant
dominic let's talk about germany
specifically i'm reading about flying
intensive care units being used by the
air force trying to reduce the strain
tell us more
yeah well the thing about the situation
in germany right now is that it is as
bad as it has ever been and it is
growing increasingly bad as the weeks
unfold so yes the luftwaffe that's the
german air force
ferrying help around wherever possible
to the places where it's needed most and
there are some states where the
situation is described officially as
catastrophic three east german state
states in the old east germany have had
10 percent or more than 10 of all their
cases have happened in the last seven
days then if you extrapolate that to a
federal level what we have is more than
360 000 cases in the course of the last
seven days and then just to add further
to the sense of the seriousness with
which people see things
the reality is in three days of the last
five there has been record cases and
today is no exception more than 76 000
new infections announced today
dominick kane updating us with the
situation across europe are reminder of
that breaking news belgium confirming a
case of this new variant